-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Sure! My pleasure. My pleasure.
-This is truly one of
my favorite movies of the year.
It's wonderful.
I also -- Before we get to it,
I want to thank you
because you were also nominated
for a Golden Globe.
You were in the audience.
I made a joke about
it was the first time men
could hear their name as
nominees and not be terrified.
And you gave me a great reaction
to that joke,
and I think it got a bigger
laugh than the joke itself.
[ Laughter ]
-I got a rubber face,
what can I say?
-You got a rubber face.
It was great.
Well, thank you so much.
So, this film, you actually --
It's about families living in
a budget hotel in Florida.
It's obviously an actual hotel
that was still running
while you were shooting.
-Right. Right.
There were residents there
around that kind of
were living the same life that
we were depicting in the film.
-You play a manager
of this hotel.
Were there times
that people who live there
thought you were
the actual manager?
-Well you know,
like, a couple of times,
they had to get us
out of the way
because they had to
check people in, for example.
We'd be in the middle
of the scene,
and they were like,
"Can you move aside?
We got business to do here."
[ Laughter ]
-And one of the other things
that was great --
There's a fantastic scene in the
movie where, as the manager,
you have to get actual birds
out of the way.
-These birds were --
They're protected.
So you couldn't touch them,
and occasionally
they'd come over to --
I think the real manager was
feeding them Cheetos.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-That's why they would come
around,
and sometimes they'd be
in our shot.
And one time the director said,
"Can you deal with that --
those birds?"
And the camera was rolling
and we went with it,
so I had a little improvised
scene with the birds.
[ Laughter ]
And they were very good.
-They were great.
-They're great partners.
-Yeah, great scene partners.
It was a wonderful scene.
I will also say, it seems like
if birds are protected,
you shouldn't be able
to give them Cheetos.
[ Laughter ]
That seems like --
-I didn't give them --
-Yeah, no look, it's very clear.
-It's the other guy.
-Yeah, throw him under the bus.
So, the kids -- Obviously,
you're a trained actor.
The kids and a lot of the actors
in this film
came from local
community theaters.
Some of them
had not acted before.
-One of the --
The mother that plays the --
Well, the mother
and the 6-year-old child
are the main performers.
And the child is 6 years old.
-Yeah.
-She's done some things,
but she's 6 years old.
-Yeah.
-And Bria, who plays her mother,
was found on Instagram.
-Yeah, she's fantastic.
-Fantastic.
And I loved performing with them
because they're very free.
They have nothing
to compare it to.
They're totally in.
They're really good
at pretending.
They're really good at just
dealing with what we're doing.
They aren't thinking outside of
what's happening.
They're very present,
and that's always a pleasure.
-And so when you
work with people
who have less experience
than you,
does it make you
feel more experienced,
or does it bring you back to
like when you were --
-I think it brings you back,
and that's what you
always want to do.
You kind of want to forget
what you know
and enter the story
on its own terms
and not think about tricks
you have or a process you need.
You know, you try to find
new ways.
-There are a lot of people
who are pulling for you
at the Oscars.
-That's cool.
-And one of them is Denis Leary.
Denis Leary tweeted,
"Really need Willem Dafoe
to win an Oscar this year
so I can be mistaken for
an Oscar winner wherever I go."
[ Laughter and applause ]
So that was very nice.
I mean, it seems
a little self-interested,
but it's still --
-It's self-interest.
-Yeah, and then,
this is pretty great.
"This morning my Uber driver
said he loved me
in 'The Florida Project'
and wondered if I was working on
my Oscar speech.
I said thank you and yes.
Then we took a photo together.
#GoDafoe."
[ Laughter and applause ]
So it is --
It's already happening.
-The only thing -- I got a beef
with Denis Leary
because he keeps on having me
take the rap for "Dumbo Drop."
-Oh, wow.
So he was in the movie
"Dumbo Drop"
and now you have to answer
questions about that?
-No, no, he always says,
"No, that wasn't me.
That was Dafoe!"
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
It's even worse.
-I've never seen the movie.
I shouldn't say it,
until I've seen it.
-That's true.
I will tell you this.
-It's a good movie?
-If he's getting credit for
"Florida Project,"
you deserve better than
"Dumbo Drop."
[ Laughter ]
Is there anyone --
Who do you get mistaken for?
-Probably the best one,
and the most --
the one that happens
the most times is --
particularly when I'm thin --
Mick Jagger.
-Okay, that's pretty great.
-And it's always
very enthusiastic.
They -- It's always, "Oh! Oh!
Mick Jagger! Mick Jagger!"
[ Laughter ]
And they're always like,
"Oh, do that thing! You know?
Come on, baby, do that thing!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which is cool. Which is cool.
I love Mick Jagger.
-Yeah.
-I grew up with Mick Jagger.
Forget that he's about
20 years older than I am.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
You got to let that go.
-He's cool.
-It seems like, because I will
say that was very good.
[ Laughter ]
It seems like you own it,
and you don't --
Do you correct people
or do you let them have
that moment and say
they met Mick Jagger?
-Better yet --
Once I was someplace --
it was in Italy,
and I went to the toilet
and I heard the kitchen going,
"...Mick Jagger. Mick Jagger."
And I get so scared that they'd
come out and ask me
for an autograph or something.
I was -- I didn't know whether I
could say, "No, I'm not him."
Or I just do it
and hope I get out
before they really ask me
to dance or sing, you know.
-The best would be if you were
in Italy and you faked it
and they immediately looked were
like, "He's no Mick Jagger."
[ Laughter ]
-That's another story.
-Congratulations.
Good luck at the Oscars.
It's just such a fantastic film,
and it's so great to have you.